i hate intros that time i got
reincarnated as a slime season one
episode one we kick things off with the
introduction of the main character
satoru mikami
he's having a bit of a rough go at it
because he's a 37 year old virgin who
hasn't had a girlfriend despite that
he's still doing pretty well in every
other aspect of his life and he goes to
meet with his friend tamara who brought
along his girlfriend mijo they plan on
going out to eat when a man suddenly
rushes tamara with a knife satoru jim's
in front of the assailant to protect him
and
ends up getting stabbed then the guy
just runs off he does what any sensible
dying man would do
and asks his boy to go destroy his hard
drive before anybody can look at it
while he's dying he hears a voice giving
him a variety of skills
he dies shortly after and starts trying
to figure out where he is now reality
sets in and he comes to the realization
that he was stabbed
killed and reincarnated as a slime not
sure what to do he goes around consuming
plants for fun he then hears the voice
that he heard while he was dying that
goes on to explain some of the skills
available to him in this life
the voice is the product of the great
sage skill that he acquired along with
other skills through the final thoughts
in his previous life
another valuable skill is predator which
allows him to ingest
objects and analyze them with his body
once he's done that he can acquire the
object's skills
or even mimic the object his stomach
also access his storage system and will
isolate harmful objects that can't be
analyzed
as a test he analyzes one of the plants
that he had eaten which was a hipokate
herb
this herb only grows in areas rich with
magicals and is used in creating salves
and healing potions
magicals are the building blocks of life
in all magical beings with his new
knowledge he uses the he poked herbs
that he had gathered to create and stock
up on healing potions he also gathers
matchy stone oars since it's considered
valuable and might come in handy later
while running around collecting
materials he comes across the dragon
when the dragon learns that he's blind
he offers to give him sight in exchange
for him not being scared when he sees
him and coming back to visit him
after receiving the site we officially
meet valdora the stormdragon which is
one of only four
true dragons that exist in this world
while talking he tells valdora that he
was reincarnated people have traveled
from other worlds before and are known
as other worlders supposedly possessing
special abilities although he is the
first one to do it through reincarnation
we then get the story of how valdora was
sealed away
300 years ago after doing some dragon
things and attacking the town a hero
blessed with divine protection had
defeated him with her unique skill
absolute severance once he was defeated
she uses unlimited
imprisonment to seal him away which is
how he wound up here not being able to
leave the cave until the unlimited
imprisonment is broken after talking for
a bit the two become friends and we get
a quick scene of tamara looking out for
his boy and destroying his desktop in
the last scene
yep feeling bad that his new buddy has
been stuck there for so long the two
agree to work together to jailbreak the
big guy
they come to the conclusion that they
have to analyze the unlimited
imprisonment from both sides
since the dragon skills were sealed away
by the hero he can't help meaning that
it's going to take some time
instead of sitting in the cave and
waiting cetera suggests putting the
dragon in his stomach while the
unlimited imprisonment is analyzed but
before they go through with their plan
valdora wants them to give each other
names
satoru comes up with the name valdora
tempest for the dragon and he becomes
known as rimuru tempest
after that rimeru uses his predator
ability to store veldora in his stomach
the news of valdora disappearing from
his cave in the great forest of juris
spread like wildfire we then get a look
at the kingdom of blumen where we get
some new faces in the
minister baron veryard and the
guildmaster fuse
the two discuss what to do about the
monsters that will likely behave
differently now that valdora isn't
around to keep them in check another
problem is that the eastern kingdom
could invade in the dragon's absence as
well fuse volunteers his services to
check up on the juror force and make
sure
everything's okay meanwhile rimaru is
just doing some grinding going around
the cave collecting any materials he
finds and slaying monsters
this provides him with an assortment of
new skills including
being able to talk out loud after
several weeks of exploring he finally
comes across the entrance to the cave
some humans happened to enter shortly
after he found it giving him his way out
he is then immediately confronted by a
group of scared goblins that came to
request his aid because they could sense
how strong he was
turns out he was giving off a pretty
insane aura which is why they were so
intimidated when they first met him
after agreeing to meet with the village
chief and his son they fill him in on
the situation now that valdora
had disappeared direwolves in the area
had been continuously attacking them the
chief's eldest son
rieger had went to fight the direwolves
with some other goblins but they were
all killed or
injured they don't have much to give in
exchange for his services because
they're broke as [ __ ] but they do agree
to serve under him and swear their
allegiance to him if he helps
episode 3. rimaru heals the wounded with
his healing potions that he had stored
away
they then proceed to fortify the village
with defenses and fight against the dire
wolves when they
attack frustrated that a mere slime
would fight back against them the
direwolves leader rushes him where he
gets tangled up in some webs into a
quick decapitation
rimaru goes on to absorb and mimic the
leader in order to use his
menace skill to deter the other wolves
from fighting this puts an end to the
conflict and the direwolves swear their
allegiance to rimaru
also not knowing how to address any of
his new followers he decides that he
will give them all names
he names the elder right and his younger
son rieger after their fallen relative
one by one he names all of the goblins
and next are the direwolves
the son of the dire wolves leader is
named ranga
after the name is bestowed primaril gets
really weak after using too many
magicals and falls unconscious
turns out giving names uses up magicals
and the reasoning behind that is that
when you give a monster a name it raises
their rank and causes it to evolve
rigor the elder is now a buff stud and
ranga is now way bigger with a unicorn
horn on his head the pack of direwolves
all had a shared name with ranga
allowing them to evolve also
during a meeting rimuru declares that
rigor to become the goblin lord to
govern the village because rimaru
doesn't want it he assigns everybody
jobs but none of them are proficient at
building or making clothes
richard suggests meeting with dwarves
who live in dwargon in order to find a
solution to these problems
episode four limaru ranga riyard and two
other goblins head for dwargon
another new face in gopta is
accompanying them as their guide since
he's been there before they make great
time and arrive after only three days
gopta and rimaru go into the city by
themselves while the others stay behind
although fighting is forbidden in the
city it's fine outside so some guys come
and antagonize them near the gate rimeru
uses his menace ability to intimidate
them but it's kind of overkill and
terrorizes everybody waiting in line to
get into the city because of the
collateral they are locked up and we
meet the captain of security kaido
after they explain the situation kaido
seems to be kind of on their side
another guard runs in and explains that
there was an armosaurus attack in the
mine and some dwarves got hurt
rimuru jumps on this opportunity to
offer up some of his potions
in return for his potions helping the
injured he is set free and kaido also
offers to introduce him to a skilled
blacksmith the blacksmith turns out to
be his older brother in
kaijin we also meet the three brothers
that were healed by rimurus potion
doored mirrored
and garm he goes on to explain that he
needs help with construction and making
clothes for the goblins but kaijen is
too busy to help
it's likely they'll be going to war soon
so he's been tasked with making 20 long
swords by the end of the week they're a
bit short on the ore necessary to craft
the sword so rimaru offers up some of
his magistone ore that he had collected
during his time in the cave
in exchange he wants kaijin to help him
hire some artisans that can go to the
goblin village and teach the villagers
crafting and construction
after the deal is struck rimuru consumes
one of the completed swords
this allows him to analyze the sword and
create 19
exact copies completing the order
instantly to celebrate them finishing
early they all go to party with some
thick elves which rimaru kind of has a
fetish for
episode 5. one of the elves offers to
look into her crystal ball and show
rimro who he's destined to be with he
peers into the crystal ball and sees a
woman with black hair
while talking minister vesta the one who
had ordered all of the swords approaches
them
minister [ __ ] antagonizes rimuru
saying that he's a monster and he
shouldn't be served in that
establishment
he even goes as far as pouring a drink
on rimuru but rimaru realizes that it's
important to not let his temper get the
best of him
kajin had a slightly different thought
process and proceeds to lay that [ __ ]
out
after handling the man child he offers
to work for rimaru instead of hiring
artisans to help the village
this all sounds good until they get
arrested for assaulting the minister
well they're locked up kaijen explains
that he used to work under this nation's
king
as a captain back in the palace minister
manchal [ __ ] was his subordinate
which he hated since kaijin was from a
peasant family while he was the son of a
marquee
shortly after that one of vesta's
projects blew up in his face so he goes
on to blame kaijin
paying soldiers to create false
testimonies to make him look at fault he
was forced to quit the force after that
but vesta still has some sort of grudge
against him and makes impossible demands
like the sword order kaijen's had enough
of his [ __ ] and is ready to leave the
town the three brothers get his back and
say that if he's going then they're
going also
now we jump ahead just a bit to their
trial where we meet king gazelle dwargo
their corrupt lawyer was paid off by
vesta to make it look like kaijin had
attacked him for no reason the king
wants to know
if kaijin would be willing to return to
his ranks instead of being punished
kaijin refuses because he had already
promised rimaru that he would assist
them at the village
since that's the case him and everybody
else are banished for their crimes
they aren't the only ones though as
vesta gets banished also for ruining the
relations with rimuru after he was so
kind to offer up his extremely rare
healing potions
after they're exiled we see the king
tasking somebody to keep an eye on
rimaru in the last scene
episode six we see fuse meeting with the
three adventurers that
let rimaru out of the cave in episode
one there is the fighter caval
the sorcerer aaron and the thief guido
they were sent out to investigate the
disappearance of veldora
the other next mission is to go back
into the forest of jura and investigate
the monster activity there before they
leave they meet a masked woman named
shizu who requests to accompany them
since she was heading that way also
when reimaru returns to the village he
finds that other goblins had come from
different villages seeking his
protection also
he lets them all in and with the help of
the dwarves they rapidly take steps
towards improving the village
back to shizu and the others who get
attacked by some ants while in the
forest
she's a bit of a badass though being
able to fight most of them off but
nearly dies to one of them forcing
rimuru to step in with his black
lightning power to save her
her mask gets knocked off in the process
and rimu recognizes her from the elves
crystal ball
her and the other adventurers are
brought back to the village to eat and
rest
when he sees his opportunity rimaru goes
to talk with shizu we learned that both
of them are actually from japan in their
old world
unlike reincarnation she was a summon
like valdora had mentioned
a summon is expected to perform as a
powerful weapon
and have a curse carved into their soul
ensuring they can't defy their master
after their conversation is over we get
a flashback of when she was first
brought to the world
she was just a kid summoned by the demon
lord leon cromwell
who initially thought she would be
useless however after a closer look he
decides to use her body as a vessel for
the fire spirit e3
episode 7. efreak can take control of
her body and use his firepowers whenever
he wishes
while she was being raised shizu had a
friend that was looking after a stray
monster the dumb friend thought it'd be
okay to bring the stray monster back to
the castle the monster then has a
hostile reaction when it sees cromwell
and e3 identifies it as a threat so he
kills it along with her friend
[Music]
after that incident shizu lives in
constant fear that eve freak could come
out at any moment and kill somebody she
loves anyways back to the present rimaru
invites her to stay at the village but
she refuses because she plans to leave
and continue searching for cromwell
well everyone is preparing to go their
own way shizu loses control of e3 and he
takes over this makes them all recognize
her as shizuei izawa the conqueror of
flames and the hero of the guild from 50
years ago rimaru
orders everybody to evacuate as e3
appears in shizu's place
the adventurers and rimuru fight against
e3 and his familiars
one of the familiars manages to close
the distance and blow itself up injuring
the three adventurers in the process
[Applause]
ranga is ordered to get the adventurers
to safety while rimiroo deals with e3
the fight is a bit lopsided because
rimaru is immune to fire damage this
allows him to use his predator ability
to purge eve free from shizu we then see
that every is stuck with veldora who
wants to fight him in rimuru's place
when shizu regains consciousness she
tells rimaru about her time spent in
this world there was a battle that
forced the demon lord to abandon his
castle and he left shizu behind as the
rear guard she fights with the same hero
that had defeated veldora
and realizes that she can't win during
the fight the two ended up talking and
the hero learned the truth of how shizu
got there and decided to take her in
they traveled around together and she
taught shizu magic but then one day
without any warning or reason she
disappeared after that shizu became a
hero also but as she got older ifrit was
getting harder to control
instead of fighting she decided to
become a teacher and taught other
worlders that had arrived in that world
after a while she decided to set out on
a new quest to find cromwell which is
when she ran into the three adventurers
knowing that her life is coming to an
end she requests that rimaru consume her
body and take up her goal of finding
cromwell he gets emotional or whatever
but now he can take on human form
three adventurers need to be on their
way but before they go rimrou hooks them
up with some new threads thanks to the
help of the dwarves
hop on over to a big boy struggling in
the heat and on his last legs
just before he dies he comes across a
man named gaelmud who offers to give the
pig boy a name
and food in the last scene episode 9. we
see that the village is coming along
nicely with everybody gladly doing their
part meanwhile rimaru experiments with
his new body which was made genderless
by the writers for
obvious reasons you can't have the
protagonist constantly defiling the dead
girl's body every other episode that'd
be weird he goes out by himself to test
out some of the other abilities that he
had gotten from shizu and one of them is
black flame
shizu also told him that the mask she
would wear has the power to suppress
magic when he puts it on his powerful
aura is neutralized making him appear as
a normal human
reamer then hears a cry for help coming
from ranga he returns to find that the
hunting party was attacked by ogres
the ogre's mistake rimrou for another
majin that they're looking for
because of his mask this leads to them
getting into a fight but before anybody
could land a fatal blow the cute pink
one jumps in to stop the fighting after
close examination of the mask they admit
that they were looking for somebody else
and they were wrong to attack them once
things calm down
they all head back to the village to
have a feast and discuss what happened
to them
episode 10 back at the village we
learned what happened with the ogres
apparently they were attacked by an orc
army led by a powerful majin wearing a
mask
they speculate that a demon lord could
be behind the attack and might be trying
to take over the forest
rimaru offers the ogres to stay with
them so that they can help each other
out if anybody runs into trouble
after he's done some thinking the ginger
leader agrees to the alliance but says
that he will only work with them until
they defeat the orcs to mark them as his
subordinates rimuru wants to give them
all names the ginger is first up and
named benny maru
his cute little sister is shuna next up
is the
thick shion the old fart is hakuro the
kind of emo
and brooding bro is away and finally the
generic normal looking dude is karobe
now we hop on over to lake sis which is
controlled by the lizardmen who had
scouted out the orc army the army has
roughly 200
000 pig boys in its ranks they come to
the conclusion that only a unique
monster called the orc lord could be
responsible for commanding such a large
force
the leader of the lizardmen requests
that his son gabiru
go find allies for their fight against
the orcs we then learned from benimaru
that shortly before their village was
attacked they were visited by lord
galmud this is also the same lord that
named rieger's older brother
he offered to give benny marrow a name
but he refused since he didn't want to
be associated with him this kind of
pissed off lord gellmute and could be
the reason the village was attacked
episode 11 the lizardmen go to multiple
goblin villages to request their aid and
have already recruited around
7 000 to fight they eventually end up at
rimaru's village and have a meeting with
him
gabiru is a little full of himself so he
offers protection if they join him and
even starts ordering them around
when he sees how strong ranga is and
learns that he's following such a weak
slime he challenges rimaru to a duel
in order to win over rhonga's allegiance
gupta ends up being volunteered for the
duel instead and gabiru is more than
happy to fight him this doesn't go so
well as gopta turns out to be a bit of a
prodigy and he uses some of his shadow
movement that he had learned to one tap
the reptile boy
another cutie chan shows up in the triad
named trainee who's requesting an
alliance with rimaru
in the last scene we learned that the
reason she had called the meeting is to
ask rimuru to defeat the orc lord
episode 12 the dryad can't confirm the
existence of the orc lord because they
know
everything going on in the forest we
also learn that the orc lord has a
unique skill
called star this means that the orcs
have an insatiable hunger and will march
on devouring everything in their path
with feeding on the dead and gaining
power being their only goals
in the end reimu decides that it'd
probably be best to work with the
lizardmen so he sends so wait to meet
with the chief
over to gabiru and the reptile boys who
are visited by a new face
in laplace a messenger from lord gelmut
he is able to convince gabby root to
take over the throne because his old man
isn't cut out for dealing with the orc
lord meanwhile zoe arrives to meet with
the chief in order to request an
alliance with the lizard men the lizard
men are hesitant so they will agree to
an alliance once they have met with
rimaru the chief orders the lizard men
to stand down for seven days until
rimaru arrives
four days in they start having run-ins
with the pig boys this cues the return
of gabiru who is informed on the current
state of things
he isn't happy with these defensive
tactics and feels that they should be
out fighting the orcs so him and his men
overthrow the chief well the chief and
his followers are imprisoned gabiru and
the lizardmen go to fight the orcs in
their marsh land
gabriel actually turns out to be a
decent strategist and it seems like it's
going well
the only downside is that he didn't know
that the orcs have the ability to power
up by eating their own dead i'm gonna be
doing part two and you can find that in
the left side whenever i'm finished with
it or you can check out all that that
time i got reincarnated as a slime
recaps in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros